it was something sis did blow over here
with GQ style and we were in Addis Ababa
Ethiopia I'm not thinking through some
of my travel gear so you know what I
take on the road so this is uh my iPhone
this is like my my mode of communication
well Charlie won't have to go what I do
is I mostly communicate with people
through Instagram Twitter snapchat and
Nigeria some the guys only did snapchat
I talked in that way
recently I hooked up with a guy mr. easy
and in Nigeria he introduced me to lot
of people as producers and I've actually
worked on the video treatment and
starting a video for a song we did just
a few days ago next week it'll be done
by they said Thursday so that's crazy
before like a song going from inception
to the video shoot they edited and done
10 days it's kind of a quick turnaround
but that's 90 RIA for you of course I
bring two laptops Miller always one it's
full of music play I had DJ with what I
do is I put all the songs for each
market on the small SD card which is
this thing right here
I kept it in my wallet right here really
except when I do this have a lot that's
the simplicity of djamena it's become
really compressed into a small format so
back to my laptop the other one is for
producing yeah that's right music on the
airplane on this program it will survive
and it's almost like these games are
nowadays in hotel rooms wrong airplanes
on this computer
well when I'm on the road I always take
vitamins have a regimen I take about
three bags of these every day it's very
important for you to try to eat well and
work out much as possible if that
doesn't always happen I kind of eat
whatever is available I tried my best to
eat healthy when I'm home so then when I
am on the road I don't feel way too much
about it
oh this watch oh you don't I watch all
spring oh this is a little more PJ many
of my friends think it's fake this guy
in candy gave it to me after my show him
I googled it to see if it was fake or
not I could figure that out but I did
find out it retails for forty thousand
euros which I I can't believe it's real
but if it is I'm gonna send my kids to
college just watch it's not I'm gonna
give it to somebody for Christmas
[Music]